Ahora consideremos expresiones con más de
una variable, supongamos que tenemos la expresión...
"a" más "b"...
"a" más "b", y nos preguntan,
¿cuánto vale la expresión cuando "a"
es igual a 5 y "b" es igual a 7?
¿cuánto es entonces "a" más "b" en este caso?
Sustituimos el valor de "a" igual a 5 más
"b" que vale 7, 5 más 7 esto igual a...
5 más 7 es igual a 12.
Hagamos otra expresión.
Supongamos que tenemos, "10x", 10 por "x"
menos... menos 3... menos 3 por 1 "y" azul...
menos 3 por "y".
Y calculemos cuanto vale esta expresión.
Cuando "x" es igual a -1 y "y" es
igual a 5, evaluémosla.
Tenemos que 10 por "x", cuando "x" es igual
a -1, esto va a ser entonces 10 por -1...
10 por -1 menos 3 por 5, -3 por "y" cuando
"y" es igual a 5, -3 por 5.
Y ahora, ¿esto cuánto nos da?
10 por -1... 10 por -1 es -10 menos 3 por 5,
por orden de precedencia hay que hacer la multiplicación primero,
así es que esto es 3 por 5 = 15, -15.
Tenemos que es -10 menos 15 y esto es igual a -25.
Y ahora, puedes hacer los ejercicios que siguen,
para practicar esto un poco más.